you know you're an award-winning writer
and yet I've heard you say that you
still find it hard composing texts
yeah it's monster I mean now when I in
my single days I was extraordinarily bad
at composing texts and I'm lucky that
I'm with someone who thinks it's okay
when I write them the worst three
paragraph text about my emotions
consistently throughout the day but that
doesn't work as well when you're in the
single flirting phase College once I
hooked up with a guy didn't hear from
him for a couple months which was not
unusual for me and then he sent me a
text it said happy new year and I said
happy new year I'm pregnant funniest
thing that it ever happened he did not
once in the morning it was got a text
over that photograph and I picked it
back I love you someone gets it well
then they might fall in love again he'll
write back
who is this dress is good at texting I
would say that I don't know what time of
night that comes down tonight when
someone should just take addresses phone
away
because did you need to send this to the
world
oh no don't do it
[Applause]
it's late you know say come over this is
me you know scrolling down and looks
away for a second look back and it has
gone Twitter send bother go send him and
I was like much worse
[Music]
yeah so we were arguing and I just sort
of lost it out and I said Oh sharp
monkey feet